dans ces convois russe siglée du z
environ 260 combattants ukrainien il
était retranché depuis des semaines dans
les usines dassault ce talent à
marioupol
53 d'entre eux sont sévèrement blessé
ils sont transportés à une cinquantaine
de kilomètres pour assistance médicale
les autres se dirigent par un couloir
humanitaire vers la périphérie de
donetsk une zone également contrôlé par
les forces russes
grâce au défenseur de marioupol nous
avons gagné un temps crucial pour former
des réserves regrouper des forces et
recevoir l'aide de nos partenaires
malheureusement nous n'avons pas la
possibilité de débloquer asos talent de
manière militaire la tâche la plus
importante de l'ukraine et du monde
entier et de sauver la vie des
défenseurs de mario paul
selon kiev avant l'évacuation près de
1000 soldats se trouvaient encore dans
les galeries souterraines de cette
aciérie devenu le symbole de résistance
des forces du craignait mais les
nombreux blessés au combat ainsi que le
manque d'eau et de nourriture ont rendu
la situation insoutenable
l'essentiel est de prendre conscience de
tous les risques d'avoir un plan b de
s'y engager pleinement d'accomplir les
tâches demandées et de préserver la vie
et la santé des troupeaux match les
autorités ukrainiennes annonce que les
soldats évacués devraient prochainement
rejoindre les territoires contrôlés par
leur armée dans le cadre d'une procédure
des changes marioupol est aujourd'hui
totalement ravagé ce port stratégique du
sud est de l'ukraine est une cible
privilégiée de l'armée russe depuis le
début du conflit